All right. All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk. Unless you have
questions if you have questions,
you're welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise, please use chat room
to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. So no class
by discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now, let me introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to
host the Hussam babae, who is
currently an assistant professor
in the Department of Mechanical
engineering and material science
at the University of Pittsburgh.
He earned his PhD in mechanical
engineering and math Master's in
applied mathematics both from
Louisiana State University in
2013. He then joined the
mechanical engineering
department at MIT for his
postdoctoral research where he
worked with Professor George
Konya Dacus. He joined the
University of Pittsburgh in
January 2017. His research is
focused on developing videos to
the model and machine learning
techniques or science and
engineering problems. His
research has been funded by many
organizations including NASA,
NSF, and NIH and the Air Force
of scientific research. Today
has some we'll talk about Kerr
matrix decomposition for
scalable reduced order modeling
of nonlinear partial
differential equations using
time dependent basis. Please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk. Now without further ado,
let me pass the baton to Hasan
by asking one random questions.
Today's random question is what
is your idea of the perfect day?
What do you find your perfect
day?
Okay, perfect day would be a
sunny day by the beach with my
family.
Oh, nice. Right now in
California. It's not a perfect
day.
My there is is here
is yours.
All right. Okay, thank you so
much Yong Soo for the invitation
and kind introduction. So, as
you said, I have been working on
on developing reducer modeling
based on time dependent basis.
So to just motivate that, and so
let me play this animation, what
you'll see on the left is a
biologically reacting flow.
These are you're seeing this
species mass production of 23
species here. And in order to
solve this equation, you have to
solve basically a system of PDE
of 23 equations. And so, you can
have larger mechanisms and you
can go up to an order of 1000
species, which I cannot show
here. Obviously, solving the
system of it is is
computationally expensive, both
in terms of memory, I Oh, and
also flop CPU cost, right. So a
floating point operation costs.
So, but as you as you saw, let
me play that again, you can see
there is a lot of similarities
or as we say, correlations
between these different species
instantaneously. And what I want
to show you that you can use
time dependent basis to both
extract and also exploit these
structures to reduce the
computational costs of these,
these these simulations, both in
terms of memory and storage. And
what I want to talk about which
is the for the focus of the
talk, is the CLR decomposition,
which I can show you that that
kind of decomposition can
improve the flops cost. So
without further ado, let me just
go so these are all of my
students and collaborators.
These are the ones who actually
contributed to some extent to
this talk. So I have my
postdocs, former postdocs and
students and also my
collaborators, Dr. Payment
Gateway at University of
Pittsburgh, Dr. Jackie Chan at
Sandia, Dr. Mark Carpenter, at
NASA Langley and our CO
professor, David Fernandez at
the University of Oregon.
Alright, so this is an outline
of my talk. So I'll just
introduce this time dependent
basis. I'll talk about some of
the stuff that we did an
application of time dependent
basis, two competing
sensitivities and also Turbulent
Combustion. Then we'll talk
about this CR factorization and
how that can be used to speed up
computation using these time
dependent bases and I'll talk
about some applications to
answer the qualification. So let
me just give you a brief
overview of I have on the flight
low rank approximation using
time dependent basis. Really the
motivation is solving high
dimensional PDS. Even in the,
when I say high dimensional, if
you discretize, that system, the
discrete vector has a very large
number order of millions to
billions. And so the way we
solve this system of equations
using traditional scientific
computing techniques, we use
this basis, we use them to
choose them from classical
techniques, it could be Fourier
methods could be polynomial
methods, polynomial spectral
polynomials, so on and so forth.
Well, we make a choice here, and
then we do suppression of virus,
this is like a traditional way
of doing scientific computing.
And actually, that choice is the
core is the root of the
problems, especially if we go to
high dimensions, where the,
these bases because they do not
exploit correlations, then the
computation resulting from this
kind of discretization suffers
from the curse of dimensionality
meaning this n scales
exponentially large with the
number of dimension. So, there
are a number of ways to tackle
this. So, one way is to do data
driven. So, let's gather data
from these observed systems and
then do some sort of dimension
reduction. You can do auto
encoder, you can do pod DMD, all
kinds of damage reduction
techniques, and then do some
sort of projection. So, this is
a typical way of, of solving
this kind of problem. But
whenever we do any kind of data
driven dimension reduction,
there is no guarantee that
whenever we build that subspace,
or manifold that that manifold
can extrapolate to unseen data,
right? So you always have that
problem. And also you have the
issue of actually having to
solve that system full or more.
Right. So it's for some of these
applications, we can even solve
that full normal at once, let
alone generating data. And so,
like I said, collectively, and
these are the challenges of
adopting a data driven type
methodologies for these massive
systems. So I'm talking about
like Fokker Planck type
equation, for example, where
just solving this ones could be
could be out of question. So the
idea is to one way, one remedy
that I've been focusing on is
actually to don't choose these
spaces, let the governing
equation find these spaces for
you in a way that exploits
correlation, right. So this is
the whole idea of of time
dependent bases, they're in an
abstract way that we don't
choose these from a classical
library, we actually let the
governing equation to find it.
And I'll show you how you can do
that for different problems.
Okay, so the idea if I want to
go back to the challenges of
data driven to do so modeling is
that can we bypass the data
generation and just directly for
solve for these for these
equations right there, there is
a way to actually make this time
dependent basis also data
treatment. I'm not talking about
those, those problems. Today,
I'm focusing on the ones that
actually we don't want to do
that generation, we do want to
directly solve the PDE. So if
you think about it, we just want
to solve the PDE by exploiting
the structure correlative
structures in the PDE. And once
we do that, we can actually
build that produced irmo on the
fly. So this is like a an
overview of reducer mining with
time dependent bases. The very,
very important distinction
between this and like pod type
decomposition is that this is
applied to matrix differential
equation. So you must have a
matrix, you have to formulate
your problem as a matrix
differential equation, and you
can extend that to also tensor
differential equation. Let's say
this is a matrix differential
equation where fee is not a
vector. It's actually a matrix.
So here I'm showing a schematic
of that, let's imagine this V is
this matrix and it has many many
columns, you can think of
application of this as a UQ
application, but each column is
a random sample of the of the
dynamical system. And if these
this matrix is instantaneously
low rank, you can approximate it
with an SVD like approximation,
this is just one scheme. I take
this as an example. And if this
is instantaneous low rank, you
can reduce an S to R and
hopefully R if this is a low
rank matrix R is much smaller
than that. And then basically,
this is an SVD like
decomposition. Within the time
dependent reducer modeling
formulation, you can actually
derive evolution equation for
all these three components
without actually needing to
generate data and these are
based on if you want to know the
background math behind this is
actually beautiful. Remind Only
an optimization where this the
rank or matrices, you can show
the rank or matrix, realize the
space of rank or matrices,
realize that this is smooth
manifold. And then you can use
that the remaining optimization
tools to do projection on that
manifold, find the tangent space
and evolve that tangent space.
So all of the math part that I'm
not going to cover today is
actually covered within the
remaining optimization. But
what's important is that like I
said, there is no data required
here other than the initial
condition and boundary
condition. So yes, that's data,
but not observation of the
physical system. Right. So and
then you can derive evolution
equation for for these matrices.
And because there is no data
evolve, right, so you this kind
of low rank approximation
doesn't even have the issue of
extrapolating to unseen data,
because there is no data
involved in the whole workflow
process. So I'll adapt to the
changing conditions. And when
and one of the nice thing about
this kind of decomposition is
that the system could be very
high rank over time, but needs
to be low rank instantaneously.
So that's the key observation,
if the system is very high rank
instantaneously, this is not an
efficient methodology. Alright,
so because of connection to SVD,
and I'll show you actually, this
is very closely related to
instantaneous SVD of that
matrix, and closely approximates
that without actually computing
any SVD than that's the key.
It's quite interpretable right,
we know how to interpret an SVD
dimension reduction.
Just some some notes actually,
this was originated in quantum
chemistry community for solving
short and get equation. And so,
this goes back actually in the
year 2000 There is this
beautiful review paper, which
shows how this kind of
methodology which you decompose
your matrix to three SVD like
matrices, that you can solve you
can use that for solving Sjodin
get equation, then in this
paper, this was put into a more
general context, right. So this
is exactly the same formulation
here, but just put into more
general context and this is now
called dynamical low rank
approximation. And, and sort of
on a parallel universe. Another
sort of decomposition, which is
a two matrix decomposition was
also developed. First we know is
by tamis, SubSys, and the
Macchu. At MIT, they developed
dynamically orthogonal
decomposition, and and later on,
George Clooney, darqueze. And
Tammy. saps has also worked
together on this kind of
methodology. And so myself, and
there was another version of
this again, a two matrix
decomposition by orthonormal
decomposition, it was shown that
do A and B are exactly the same
thing. There's also two two
matrix decomposition, optimally
time dependent decomposition
that is applied to linear
systems, which I worked with. I
worked on that and also there is
dynamically orthogonal duallie,
dynamical orthogonality
conditions, sorry, there's a
typo here. What is this, all of
these terminologies may sound
confusing, but I want to show
you that they all of these are
actually equivalent to each
other. Right? So actually, we
show that in this paper that you
can, that this dynamical low
rank approximation, this triple
matrices are actually is like a
hybrid of do and build together.
And they are equivalent. What do
I mean by equivalent, they are
exactly the same low rank
matrices proximation of the full
matrix. And so so as you see,
throughout this talk, I use this
or this, but you shouldn't get
distracted by any of these
triple matrix decomposition or
two matrix decomposition. What
is important to know is that
they all follow the same
principle, and they are
equivalent. Okay, let me show
you an example of that before I
get to the CLR decomposition for
competing sensitivities how you
can use this kind of app this is
an application of the VDS or
mine based on time dependent
basis. So this is applied to
compute sensitivities of lots of
high dimensional systems. So if
you want to compute sensitivity
of a high dimensional system,
let's say this is an nonlinear
dynamical system. Now, you want
to perturb this with respect to
some sort of parameters for each
of those parameters, you would
have to solve this linear
sensitivity equation, right? So
obviously, if the number of
parameters is large, this is not
a cost effective way. That's why
people use our joint equation
for agile equation, you only saw
one equation backward in time.
So you have to solve the forward
equation and then solve one
equation backward in time and
then compute sensitivities for a
given objective function with
respect to all the parameters,
but there is like two major
problems with that joint one is
actually i o because you have to
store the full forward model and
then and then to solve the
actual equation backwards in
time. So that I O is actually a
major problem, especially for
massive simulations like
Turbulent Combustion problems
where you can't store the
forward solution at all in a
time resolved manner. And also
agile, you have to do diversion
for any any given parameter for
any given objective function. So
if your objective function
changes, you have to do another
agent equation. But so yeah, so
now let's look at it from a
completely different
perspective. And that is that
these sensitivities, so if you
look at these sensitivities,
these are actually different
sensitivities, respect to
different parameters, they are
correlated to each other
instantaneously. If they are
correlated, you don't need to
solve for each one of those. And
you can actually solve for a
compressed version of those
forward into, alright, so that's
really the key observation here.
And so if you look at this, this
is again, you have a matrix
differential equation. So you
can look at the sensitivity
equation as a matrix
differential equation where
you're evolving all of these
sensitivities together. And like
I said, if these are low rank,
you can, you can compress them.
So this is this work I was
published last year in Siam. And
this is, I'm using the Dubai
decomposition here. But like I
said, you can actually derive a
triple decomposition here. So
instead of solving for of this
sensitivity, solve for only a
rank r, would hopefully R is
much smaller than D, solve for
d. So you need to solve PDE. So
this is not cheap to solve
either. But at least you solve
PDS of order R instead of d. And
then these are really
projections of the pool or more
onto these bases. And this is
where you get these coefficients
by wrong, this approximation of
this matrix is instantaneous
law, right? It's a good
approximation. And, and that's
it. So the way we swap, we find
the evolution equation for you.
And why is by forming a
variational principle, this
variational principle is nothing
but the residual that you get,
because we are doing a low rank
approximation. So instead of the
whole matrix of sensitivity, we
put you by transposing the full
Ormeau. And because it's a low
rank approximation, this is not
going to be zero. But this is
going to be some nonzero we want
to minimize this by optimally
updating the low rank basis, you
and the coefficient, subject to
this other normality condition,
we want these bases to be
orthonormal, you can actually
solve this with Lagrange
multiplier. Once you solve this
equation, you get this close on
evolution equation for these
bases and the coefficients, and
then you solve this, instead of
solving this equation. And
that's where you get the
computational advantage, right,
instead of solving for the
fields, you solve for our
fields. And d over r is what you
get in terms of memory, saving,
and also in terms of in terms of
flops. So this is now we applied
this to the same problem was
showing you at the very first
slide, this is the biochemical
reactions, biological reaction.
So these, these are reaction
parameters. And it's very
important to know how any
quantity of interest is
sensitive to any of these
parameters, because the
competing these measuring these
quantities is very expensive.
And you you can't afford to
measure all of them super
accurately, you have to do a
budget allocation and say, okay,
these 10 parameters are
important, and which are those
10 parameters. There are other
applications as well. But this
is just one skill, some other
reduction is another one. So you
can actually drop these
reactions if they're not
important if they're not, if the
nothing is sensitive with
respect to those and actually
come up with the reduced
mechanism. So if you look at
this, this is actually a tensor
because you've got like here 23
species, and we have 34 reaction
parameters, if you look at the
entire matrix, the entire
sensitivity is actually a
tensor, you have parameters, you
have a species here and then you
have grid points, but, so, here
what we do we flatten this
tensor and then becomes a
matrix. So, these are the
sensitivities of different
species with respect to
different parameters and then we
seek to approximate this with
this low rank approximation. So,
instead of solving 23 by 34,
PDS, which would be forward
sensitivity equations, or if you
want to solve an equation, you
have to solve an agile equation
for each of these species or
instead of solving 23 Agent
equation, we want to do a low
rank approximation of this and
see what we get, we did that. So
this particular formulation is
called force optimal time
dependent decomposition or fotd.
Like I said, it's a particular
variation of that time dependent
basis just apply to linear
sensitivity equation, I can see
increasing grant from two to
eight you can this is relative
error, you can actually match
you can reduce the error
significantly. So this is with
with five mods you can get less
than one person error, relative
error. And this would be
optimal. We show we actually
took resolve the full Oromo all
of the sensitivities and we took
instantaneous SVD of that that
will be the best and lowest
error that one could achieve and
we see actually we are tracking
the instantaneous SVD very well,
like I said, we when we solve
these equations, we do not take
any SVD this is all evolution
equation, but the evolution
equation is such that they
approximate this instantaneous
SVD. And you can see here the
singular values match with the S
instantaneous SVD. So, that
means we are actually very, very
closely tracking the optimal sub
space here. And with five modes
basically is equivalent, the
cost of solving for five modes
is equivalent solving five PDS
for five sensitivities as
opposed to 782. And also memory
storage is also the same we saw
basically, we only need to
restore five modes, the
coefficients, those are in terms
of restoring that those are
negligible. And so, but it can
visualize them,
I can go back to the previous
slide I, I don't usually stop
the presentation, but I had to
because I'm, I'm looking
something so you're, so you're
solving five PDE instead of 782.
So, so from those five PDE IDs,
you generate the data and Ami.
But you said that you're not
using the data to construct this
evolutionary equations, am I
missing something actually
constructor, so
it's off Wi Fi, these are five
of these modes, and also you
solve an OD for the evolution
equation, anytime you want, you
can reconstruct the full order
of sensitivities
and include this matrix matrix.
So
you solve for these two matrices
as shown here, five PDS Yeah,
the cost of this is really
negligible compared to this. So
five PDS and OD E with this is
the wrong basically, but wrong
is a instantaneous projection of
your full or mo onto this basis.
And based on that, you can
reconstruct, you can multiply
these two skinny matrices and
reconstruct the full
sensitivities anytime you want,
but we don't do that I mean, but
you can do that at any any point
you want,
and where the where the
parameter comes in
or the forcing, they show up by
forcing in the sensitivity
equation, right. So, when you
take the linear sensitivity, you
take the derivative of your full
normal with respect to these
parameters, they show us forcing
in the right hand side of the
NCCF shows up in all of these
equations. Okay. Sure. Okay. And
also, this actually, we have the
details you can find in this
paper, if you're interested. And
so, let me go back to this
slide. So, you can see actually,
the modes here like I said, this
is interpretable the modes
actually captured the structure.
So, this is the first mode the
second or third mode, you see
actually captures finer and
finer structure. So these are
the time dependent cyberspace
that is evolving with your
system, and like this is a
convection dominated problem. So
you cannot solve these problems
with POD static basis, you have
to resort to some sort of basis
adaptivity and I know Jung Soo
and also others actually have
worked on adaptive basis, but
this is a matrix differential
equation. So I think that's
really the difference here, not
the vector revolution equation
and also Benjamin pass refer and
Karthik also, University of
Michigan also worked on adaptive
basis, but, but this is like I
said, this is a matrix
differential equation. Anyway,
so, you once you solve this
problem, you can actually take
your y one and reconfigure that
because this will be remember
this was a tensor with flatten
that and then you can actually
see the sensitivities with
respect to of all the species
with respect to all 34
parameters, this is just one of
them out why one just visualize
here and you can see which
parameters is affecting which
species immediately like I said,
this is this actually has that
simplified data representation
that is immediately explainable
interpretable so I want to talk
about application Turbulent
Combustion. This is another
application where you have a
matrix differential equation.
Let's look at that. So to
everyone combustion, you have to
solve this compressible navier
stokes equation, I'm taking
DNSBL but this could be rands or
alias, but then you need to
solve this species transport
equation. And for complex views,
you may have even order of 1000
species. So this is solving this
equation is really the major
costs of solving Turbulent
Combustion because you have to
first store this 1000 species,
which is really just out of
question for under DNS, great
just storing a matrix with 1000
species is out of question, and
that is really the main
bottleneck. And also the I O
cost like it this is actually
this one 2012 from Dr. Jackie
Chan's group that and simulate
this is a direct quote from the
paper that because of I O
limitation, we can only store
like for every 400 trimesters of
the solution. This is three
dimensional simulation, whereas
there are things happening or
the order of 10 simulation time
is completely missed. If you
store the data every 400 times.
So this is just i Oh, it's you
can imagine the memory and
solving the system and this is
not for the 1000 species I think
This is order of 100 species. So
as we push this boundary to
exascale computing, especially
when memory and IO are the main
issues actually solving this
equation is a major challenge.
And so how but if you look at
this equation, this is a matrix
differential equation and
nonlinear matrix differential
equation. And again, now here
I'm using the tuple
decomposition, but like I said,
You shouldn't get distracted by
to decompose by decomposition or
cheaper decomposition, they are
equivalent. So then you have
this matrix decomposition, you
can write this. So the this is a
full order model evolution
equation. Again, you can follow
the same principle, which is a
residual minimization, plug in
this kind of low rank
approximation. And this is a low
rank approximation. So you've
got some error here and plug it
in here, because it's a low rank
approximation is not going to
satisfy the full remark. So you
get this residual, and you want
to minimize that residual by
optimally updating all three
components. Once you solve this
minimization problem subject to
the Arthur normality of view
modes and y modes, then you get
evolution equation here, you can
find the details here in this
paper. But just suffice to say
that we are solving this solving
this doesn't require some
optimism, some iteration or
anything, you get evolution
equation as the optimality
conditions. So the evolution
equations are the optimality
condition. So you don't need to
solve a nonlinear optimization
problem, and so on, so forth.
This, these are the optimality
conditions. So it's not like
that you actually solve a
gradient basis. These are
actually what minimizes, if you
if you and Sigmund was satisfied
this governing equation, you're
minimizing this residual. So we
applied these two different
views, I'll just show you a
sample of this, this is a two
dimensional Flog. This is GRI
mechanism actually has quite
complex chemistry, he's got 53
species and 325 reactions. So
this is a direct numerical
simulation of that we are
showing contours of temperature
and O H. And this is a rank six
approximation of this instead of
solving for 53 species, we are
solving for six effective the
species. And so we have done
more analysis here, I just all
those results are in this paper
that hopefully will be out soon.
But I want to show you that like
I said, for practitioners, these
are this is not just a way to
speed up computation, this is
actually interpretable. So if
you focus on the Y modes, here,
the Y modes represent as a time
dependence of a space in the
comp in the thermal in the
composition of space, right, so
if you look at the composition
of space is a 53 dimensional
space. And each of these vectors
is so this collectively is a
subspace and I can visualize
that cyberspace and also we have
done instantaneous PCA that
means instantaneous SVD of this
matrix. And we show that this
time dependent bases actually
closely follow the the
instantaneous PC, PCA, but there
is also PCA that is done in
combustion community.
Unfortunately, I don't have to
cover that. But that's really
equivalent to like a pod
approach. But for composition
space, so that's static, you can
see that the especially the
higher modes vary in time a lot.
And you can look at the singular
value the singular values of
that matrix. So we solve the DNS
of that and we computed the
singular values of that. And
then we can see the singular
values. With this low rank
approximation, we can capture
the leading modes very well. And
these are, so I want to go over
this just in the interest of
time, but if you're interested
in this, we have a lot more
details in this manuscript. And
so we have extended this to
three dimensional simulation as
well. This is for a different
mechanism saying yes mechanism,
it's similar and you can see the
modes. Now the modes here are
three dimensional modes. And
this is a DNS mixture fraction
of DNS, but these are the modes
want the first mode the second
or third mode, you can see the
modes actually evolved with the
flow, and they add that to the
flow. This is another case done
in Dr. Jackie Chan's group. And
so this actually has a sudden
transition at the end. So
there's a propagation of this
wave from right to left and then
when it gets near the end, you
will see a sudden transition in
the chemistry and so, all the
disaster 39 species
This is solved in std COVID
Eight or defined difference and
all these details are here. Let
me just show you. This problem
is actually very high rank even
this month, so we had to choose
r equals to 29. So we are not
really getting so much reduction
here. And this is actually I
want to show you this as one of
the challenges of solving these
systems. That is instantaneous
is not that low rank was still
you go from 39 to 29, you can
see this, we can get the
transport, but there's this
sudden transition at the end
that is kind of time dependent
bases can capture that sudden
transition. And if you look at
and also this is a convection
dominated problem. So this kind
of reduce or mine handles
convection really well, as I
mentioned earlier, if you look
at the composition of a species
yet, you will see at the end,
these two modes drastically
change in time. The higher modes
usually change in timing, in
older cases that we have
considered, but not the first
two modes. And you can see at
the end, once this animation
approaches the end, these are
the two most energetic modes,
you can see that that
composition changes drastically
towards the end, as you saw here
as a, this is actually an
extremely challenging problem to
solve. All right, now, I want to
get to the CLR decomposition,
this was really an introduction
to this, I wanted to talk about
some of the other challenges,
especially how to solve this
system of equations efficiently
for for nonlinear, governed for
nonlinear PDE s, right. So if
you look at the evolution
equation, this is this is this
is evolution equation I showed
in the previous slide, but just
simplified in terms of linear
algebra. So you solve an
evolution equation for four
modes U and sigma and why when
but if the right hand side of
the governing equation is
nonlinear, so this is the right
hand side of the governing
equation, you have to compute
this F, which is a nonlinear map
of your governing equation. If
you form this matrix, first of
all, you lose all the advantages
that this methodology has to
offer, because you have to
occupy the entire memory and
then apply this nonlinear map on
that decompress matrix. Even
though when we come back here,
we'll project it back to this
other space. But this is the
same problem that exists in
nonlinear, reduced order
modeling with POD also, we have
the same issue. And this is
exactly the same issue that
shows up here. So you have you
need to do some sort of hyper
reduction here. And I want to
show you that CLR is actually
the way to do hyper reduction
here for this matrix
differential equation. So there
are four issues with this is
issue of cost, which is the one
we are targeting here. And also
if you want to get efficiency
with solving this equation, if
your governing equation is
nonlinear, like a combustion
problem, or a UQ problem, if it
is quadratic non linearity, you
can get the speed up solving
this equation by just plugging
in this expansion into the
governing equation and work out
in a painstaking way, all the
terms and solve this evolution
equation, but that's highly
intrusive, so you can get
efficiency for nonlinear
equation, but at the cost of
doing an extremely intrusive
process. Those two, these two
are really the major drawbacks
of this kind of formulation. And
so we wanted to see if we can
actually go back and and be able
to solve this system of equation
for a generic non linearity, but
keeping the cost the as low as
solving just for only our
samples of this equation, right.
So our samples are is the rank
of the reduction, that is the
nominal cost of solving this
equation, and also rank
adaptivity. And also stability
when there are two other issues
with this system. So first of
all, our doesn't have to be
fixed, right? So the rank of a
system evolves over time. So
just fixing that, that's a
problem. So, these problems
actually have been this issue of
inverting this matrix have been
addressed in this beautiful
work. But reformulating this
problem to another problem, and
actually resolving this issue of
having various having to invert
this matrix, this matrix could
become ill conditioned,
remember, this is a singular
value matrix. And if you want to
solve this system with high
accuracy, you need to resolve
very small singular values. And,
and so this is so you, so you
have to be able to invert this
matrix, this integration scheme
actually resolves that issue by
the cost of three pill. The cost
of solving this is a scheme
proposed here is triple of the
cost of two times as large as
the cost of solving this system,
but it doesn't have this issue.
Rank adaptivity also has been
proposed here with work of
Daniella venturi for tensile
revolution equation and also
within this formulation, but not
the issue of cost. So these two
issues have not been addressed
up to this point. And that's
really, I feel like these are
major bottlenecks of solving
this equation and getting the
scale that they can offer. Okay,
so let me just go to. So the all
the details here is in this
paper that was recently
published by myself and my, my
student, Jose no dairy. So let
me just give you an overview. So
here I'm switching to a UQ
problem, that's another
application, where you actually
UQ problem, you can formulate it
as a matrix differential
equation here, but all the
samples are. So if you look at
the UQ problem, you have a
nonlinear differential equation,
and you have some random
parameters. So this is the
matrix of all the samples where
each column is one sample. And
you want to do a low rank
approximation of this matrix.
Like I said, computing this f of
V is as costly as solving the
fuller Mall. So that's the thing
you'll be wanting to work for
generic non linearity. If the
system is linear, like the
examples I showed at the
beginning, you can actually work
it out and solve this system in
the Compress for you. And you
can actually achieve all the
computational efficiency, but
not if this system is nonlinear.
And so the cost of this system
if you don't handle this
properly, it will scale with the
number of rows and number of
columns of this matrix and that
exactly the cost that you want
to avoid, you want to have this
cost. So like I said, for linear
quadratic system, we can do that
at the cost of doing a highly
intrusive process. So the
question is, how can we reduce
the computational cost of
solving a rank or tdb wrong time
dependent basis wrong to that of
solving only to our samples of
that full or more, that is the
nominal cost of evolving these
equations. So this is so that I
want to explain CLR, which is
really fantastic. And I believe
under explored linear algebra
decomposition. So this is, let
me just explain that. So let's
say you have a matrix G. And
this matrix has low rank
structure, right. So this you
can approximate it like if you
take SVD of this matrix with
bank or you can approximate it
well, you can actually get
something super close to an SVD
of this matrix by strategically
sample the columns and rows of
this matrix, all the blue ones
and all the all the red ones.
And then you can approximate
this means this should be an
approximation, but just the
columns of this which are shown
by blue color, and the rows of
this matrix, which are shown by
red and this matrix, which is
the, the intersection of these
inverted, and arrays. If you
select these rows and columns,
strategically, you can get
something very close to an SVD.
And this was shown by Sorenson
Embry that this is dying induced
car decomposition. Alright, so
we adopted
the same strategy here. In fact,
we didn't know about this, I
have to confess and we did
develop this methodology. And
later on, we show that actually,
this is exactly as you are the
composition. So instead of f of
t is the right hand side of the
governing equation. So we can be
only sample that equation at
these columns and rows, not that
so anything you see here in
gray, that is not computed. And
based on that, we can compute
this, you can also do triple or
by decomposition of this matrix.
So we compute this by by
sampling the columns, you find
the column space for the ortho
normalize, that will be denoted
by fee of D, this is really Q R
of the columns that we sample.
And then these are just the
interpolation coefficients that
you can get it by the by
interpolating every other column
of these matrix to these spaces.
So this is an interpolate matrix
interpolation, not a matrix
project, not a matrix
projection, that is very
important. So there is really
nice. This is actually an
oblique projection rather than
an orthogonal projection. So
unfortunately, I don't have time
to cover all of that. But the
key is that, remember, we didn't
want to compute this matrix
entirely, we wanted to compete
it only that was the cause.
Right? So but if but this matrix
does have low rank structure, if
didn't have low rank structure,
we wouldn't be able to do this
time dependent basis to begin
with. And so if it has a lot on
construction, you can actually
strategically sample this, the
sampling strategy is based on
direct empirical interpolation
method. I'm not going to go over
this all those details are in
the paper how we do this. So we
need to have SVD of the these
methods to know where to sample
we don't have this matrix to
begin with, let alone the SVD of
this, we use the previous time
step SVD of the previous time
step of this matrix which we
have cheaply, and use those as
as as to derive to tell us where
to sample right. So that's an I
don't want to go over all of
this, it all details on that
paper. And so this is really an
overview of this strategy. Like
I said, instead of f the key is
that instead have F now we have
two skinny matrices that we can
plug in here. So instead of
putting F here, remember, F was
the source of all the all the
each computational issues. Now
we have a skinny factorization
that is plugged in here. Once
you plug that in here, these are
extremely fast. And I mean, and
also, it's really nice that this
is actually relatively non
intrusive, because you only saw
sort of the fuller mouth, you
sample the fuller mouth and the
right hand side, this is
strategic columns. And you only
need to sample it at these grid
points. These are different grid
points. So this act, you don't
need to derive a new set of
equations for any new PDE
solver, you can actually just
use use this. In fact, there is
a way to extend this to even
blackbox solver and we are
working on that. And to make
this actually non intrusive.
Because these systems up to this
point are worse extremely
intrusive to solve it takes few
months of time to just implement
it in a in a typical final
element called
sorry. Has some arm the previous
slide. So though it's the sample
job dependent on time, so every
time steps is exactly the
changing
district. Exactly. Because these
will be done with a fixed
sample, you wouldn't be able to
do this. And I'll show you next
in the demonstration that
exactly that's That's exactly
right.
Is it implementation of that?
It's
kind of interesting. No,
well, you need to have access to
the F right hand side, right. So
yeah, right. So you can get it
for sampling the fuller mall,
but the rows are rows are
intrusive. Because rows, you're
actually need to know the terms
of the equation. So that's the
part to know all the terms in
the governing equation.
And that's changing every time
step. So
these rows and columns change
every time you scan, it will
look at this SVD and
approximation or SVD of the
previous time as above F and
based on that or update this.
Yes. And this, this kind of
approximation, like I said, is
quite rigorous actually. So
instead of approximating it,
basically we're approximating
the entire matrix of f, we then
f hat, which is a CR
decomposition, which is this
aprox, this multiplication of
these two skinny matrices, you
can show actually, the
difference between the full
matrix and this approximation in
the second norm is sigma p one,
if we were doing SVD, here, this
error would be exactly equal to
sigma p plus one, this would be
the P plus one a singular value,
here, we only get this a scaling
of these two numbers. So times
the optimal error that you can
get with the rank, rank or
approximation and dying
procedure. And these are the
condition number of the
interpolation matrices. And
dying procedure, in fact, is a
greedy procedure to minimize
these two numbers. So you get
really small numbers for these
two. So you get That's what I
said, you get actually something
similar to an SVD. That's,
that's what I mean, but without
actually forming that matrix at
all. And, and you can form or
you can make this number of
sample points also adaptive
because you can look at the last
singular value that you're
resolving divided, you can come
up with different error, error
criteria, but you can look at
the last singular value divided
by the summation of the results
singular value. And if that's
not within the bounds that you
want, you can add with a sample
F, add one more columns, and one
more rolls. So let me show you
some application to UQ. So this
is a stochastic burgers
equation, the randomness comes
from the initial condition and
the boundary condition. And
we're using a spectral element
to solve this equation. And so
you can see here the singular
values, let me show you that
because in the interest of time,
I'm going to show you the speed
of actually get, and then I'll
show you some of the error. So
this is tdb. Wrong. This is if
you don't use this kind of
methodology. This is how the CPU
time scales as you increase the
number of grid points. So n is
the number of grid points the
number of rows, but this one
actually scales linearly. And so
and also this is as you increase
the number of samples, so as the
number of scales linearly, again
here, but as your answer when
you ask the time points are time
dependent, and that's exactly
the case. So we can use Dine or
Q Dine, which is based on QR
decomposition. And this is
burgers with the with sharks. So
you see the shot two sharks
here. And you can see here that
actually, the time points are
changing with time this axis is
time. This is just I'm just
showing the row points, right.
So I'm not showing the columns
because there's a sparse
sampling in the column as well.
And you can see the Q diamond
dam actually captured almost the
same points. So one, one
immediate way you can see the
advantage of this if you go to
the full or like the way we were
doing these things before, we
were actually competing the
right hand side that all of
these great points right now we
are only competing the right
hand side at these points. So
that's just that just tells you
one One quick way to To see how
efficient this is, and here we
are comparing the modes that we
extract by doing this kind of
approximation with carbon and
over approximation of the full
normal, which is the optimal
base instantaneous spaces. And
you can see, we have shock, and
we are capturing the full amount
really well. This is another
example burgers equation has
quadratic non linearity, maybe
you were able to do, you can do
that intrusively, and still get
efficiency, but not even even
you do it intuitively, you're
not going to be as efficient as
this methodology. But here this
is a compressible flow rather
than a linearity is non
polynomial. So, you have
actually rho u divided by rho,
so you have non linearity of
fracture non linearity. And if
we discretize, this system, we
have 262,000 rows, and then we
have 200,000 samples. So, this
is the case, if you want to do
UQ. Here, you can even store
this matrix in memory, like, we
saw this CPU, and the laptop
CPU. So, you can even store this
on the laptop CPU. So, we never
actually during the workflow, we
never store the full matrix. And
we only do this as per sampling.
And you can see here, first, we
did it for a small number of
samples. So we can actually do
error analysis. So we did here
for 200 samples, and we show
with this as per sampling, we
recover. So this is the tdb rom
if you don't do sparse sampling
the blue line, but this is tdb
wrong with six sparse samples,
20 and 20 spot samples, this is
for Diamond Q dime, and CB 20
samples, we can actually recover
almost the ones that you don't
do this for sampling. And like I
said, P is adaptive. So P
changes in time. So how many how
many samples you have for the
right hand side, you can
actually adaptively adjust that
to keep the error of this your
approximation below a given
threshold. And you can see, as
time goes on the actually get
different numbers of p. So these
are number of samples. This is
actually when it's a time
dependent. So this is actually
this is the mean and the
variance and you can see the
sample points actually captures
the action here where the action
happens. And like I said, this
is now with 200,000 samples. And
these are the samples in the
column space, which you can see
actually, they are located on
the joint pdf of y one and y
two. And we did convergence
study here by increasing number
of going points. And you can see
we are converging in the
instantaneous singular values.
By increasing the rank of the
system, we are still converging
by increasing the number of
samples from 100,000 to 100,000.
And we get convergence all of
this is also in that paper. All
right, I think I'm almost out of
time. I'm already out of time.
So let me just conclude here at
this is the way I see this this
field. And the contribution that
this kind of reducer modeling
can do. So if you look at the
way we were we are doing
classical scientific computing,
we do suppression of variables,
we put time and the coefficient
and we choose the bases, right.
So you've got these bases that
you can choose from that
library. I think another way of
solving this equation, which is
a structure resolving you don't
actually this skater is a great
you're actually captured linear
nonlinear correlation is by
doing physics informed neural
network, I know Paris is online.
And basically you don't. One way
to look at physics and form
Neural Network is that you're
not choosing the basis, you let
the optimization process to find
the optimal places for you.
Right, so that so that is
another way to break the curse
of dimensionality and applying
this to high dimensional
problem. That's why it's
advantageous. This is also
another way of doing that. But
here, we don't solve a nonlinear
optimization problem, right. But
like I said, this has also its
own limitation, but But you
don't choose the basis again,
from a library, you let it
evolve the time. And you the
physics of your equation. And
the residual of the governing
equation really determines that.
So yeah, here we apply this to
to the problem here. This is
compressible, Navier. Stokes,
and you can see the basis
actually evolves, these are
bases in the 1x, two direction,
these are bases in the x one
direction, and CB bases
adaptively evolve in time, I
mean for this kind of problem is
not really important to use
these bases. But for high
dimensional problem, this
localization and adaptivity of
the basis is really the key to
break the curse of
dimensionality because you don't
want to put degrees of freedom
in places, especially in high
dimensional spaces. You don't
want to waste because of
freedom. And so this can
actually effectively do that.
And we have applied this to
tensor evolution equations as
well, which I didn't have time
to cover that today. Maybe some
other time. Yeah. And so this is
where I see the place of the so
it's actually it's got good
connections with classical
computing and also with machine
learning in in a way because
this is a low rank
approximation. Alright, so with
that, I'll thank you and I'll
take any questions.
Wonderful. Wonderful. Thank you
so much. Awesome. Oh, very
interesting. Okay, so let's have
a q&a session. So we do have a
question from Pat. Pat. Are you
online?
Yes. Hey,
okay. Yeah. Why don't you ask
questions directly?
Thanks. think those were I
really liked the the images and
stuff that I think they they
really helped. But I did have
trouble understanding what the
what the reduced set dimensions
correspond to what are they?
What are they representing? Are
they friendly? In the chemical
example? For example? Are you
talked about having lots of
species? The new, the new basis?
Does each one correspond to an
algebraic combination of the
original species? Or is it
something else?
That's right. So every one of
those, let me go back to that
example. That's exactly right. I
think you said it at the end.
That, so if you look at this
matrix as a matrix of the oldest
species, we don't solve for
these directly we solve for
these modes, each of these modes
are really a linear combination
of all of the species.
Okay. Yeah, it's always linear.
It is always linear.
But you can actually extend this
to nonlinear answers as well.
And that's why they're working.
And that is actually, I think,
the next really problem.
So there might be cases where
some of the species are
effectively have to have no
influence at all. But and
there's others where there's
really a mixture of them, but it
my guess is, there's certain
kinds of things that go on
there, like you would probably
ever have. My guess is that
there would be the species would
be clustered or some, right? I
don't know if that's true. But I
can imagine that being true.
Absolutely.
And that's exactly right. So
that's, so what you're talking
about is actually this, maybe
not one global time dependent
basis, but you can actually
localize that or you get into
composition, especially in the
physical space. And I have an
absolutely, so we are actually
exactly working on that idea as
well. And, and, and UBC actually
amazing improvement compared to
just using one oil global,
I believe that I believe it
speeds things up, I just want to
understand what's going on. So
these are like the species are
like gang members, they hang out
together. Exactly. They travel
the same put together and so on.
Okay, got it. Thank you.
Alright. Then I had a second
question about the car work,
which seems very different. So.
So in one example, you showed
the some of the points, and it
looked like those were the
points that had sort of the
extreme values. Was that
is? That's right. So let me show
the burgers equation. Exactly.
So I think so what they actually
these points correspond to so
they actually concentrated over
the shocks. Right? So there are
two shocks here, right? So and
the dime algorithm in a clever
way actually picks up. So you
don't need to sample this at all
of the points here, you only
need to sample it at these
points. But this is usually
where action happens.
When I when I turn on the
Weather Channel, and someone
tells me well, there's a front
moving through here, it's sort
of like that, you can dare
they're trying to identify the
the interesting that this
continuities or, or, or major
change kind of kind of areas.
In fact, one thing you can
immediately see if you look at
the damn procedure, if these are
these are the two modes that are
visually These are often almost
each other. And so the time the
first time point, if I want to
the first the most important
point is where this mode is, has
a maximum value. That's actually
the first point which is that is
the if you want to pick one
point in your system at that
instant of time that has the
most variance that's this point
here. So it picks that one and
then it sort of recursively
takes out this mod out of the
system and see what's left with
the leftover then it starts in
an A greedy way to pick up more
points and it does that it's
like a sort of a like a QR type
approximation you'd layer by
layer with each point you pick
out what they are will be
concentrated. So you see these
modes are highly non local,
highly localized, right? So
they're very localized near the
shot and between they're sort of
flat. So Dan doesn't actually
pick those points and brilliant
methodology.
Okay, thank you very much. Good.
Okay, next question is from
Maryam Maria Maria online. Yeah,
I
am online. Okay, you can
actually ever I'm taking too how
extent to what extent the metals
could be used It's come to my
mind that what are the exact
conditions or requirements that
PDE should have to can be
applicative?
Excellent question. So remember
when I said at the beginning,
these are low rank approximation
for matrix differential
equation? Number one, you have
to formulate your problem as a
matrix differential equation
one, and then second, you need
to see if that matrix
instantaneously has low rank. If
your problem meets these two
criteria, then this is a really
good method to use. If not,
that's not the end of the story.
That's actually a topic of
future research.
And maybe it's out of context.
But just let me know if it
doesn't make sense. The method
is, is mainly developed for a
time dependent PDS if you have
another type of tape PDS that is
partial differential but doesn't
include the time do you think
it's applicable to?
You can do the absolutely you
can do that for actually there
are a lot of nice result
theoretical results for the
steady state PDS. So first of
all, this this time iterations
would become this time evolution
becomes iterations in that
context, and you can, you can
take much larger leap and steps
to convert, so you're not
limited by the time so there are
other algorithms that you can
use to jump over that. And then
then you can show actually
converge to the SVD of that
results. So there are a lot of
nice things you can show. But
yeah, absolutely, that you can
apply this to steady state
problems. Thank you.
Well, following on Marian
questions, you know, if you
don't have a time dependent time
stand, instead you have a 3d as
your space show domain is 3d,
then you can make them to matrix
equations. by decomposing each
dimension into ones you couldn't
really
use. There are I mean, even one
dimensional equation can be
turned into a matrix
differential equation. So it's
really that's actually where you
have to be able to say a 3d
problem can become, in a number
of ways can become a matrix
differential equation, right? So
you can take the 2d slab as one
direction, x one and x two and x
three is another direction,
right? So that's, or you can
even do this for the tensor
evolution equation, which I
didn't talk about, right? So
that's another way. So if a 3d
problem naturally fits within a
tensor evolution equation, and
sensor evolution equation of
this system is very similar to
what I just presented, all the
principles are the same. And you
can derive that. But like I
said, there are a number of ways
you can make your size. So So
for example, if you have a 1d
example, no time dependence, how
would you make it matrix
equations? You have only one
variable,
you can do domain decomposition
and put them next to each other.
That's one way. I see.
Interesting, interesting. Okay,
so. Any other questions? From
audience? No, we actually hit
the 11 o'clock punctually. All
right, magically. Well, thank
you so much for the wonderful
talk. And sounds like you have
more topics to talk about.
Let's, you know, reserve that
for the second. Yeah. Well,
let's thank our invited speaker
has them for the wonderful talk.
And yeah, so
thank you so much. Appreciate
the opportunity.
Yeah, I learned a lot. And I, I
promise you I'm going to look
into this deeply.
Yeah, exactly. It's stuff you
do. Actually, this is very
relevant. Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah. All right. Sounds good.
Thank you so much.
If you can share the slide with
me. That would be wonderful.
Okay, obviously, you can do
that. Yeah, sure.
Absolutely. All right. Well,
thank you so much. All right.
Thank you. Bye bye. All right.